大家好,我是清華大學研究生劉百慶
很榮幸能夠為大家帶來本次基於Secret Note
再慶平台的影子計算案例模範
也是講解視頻
案例名字為新冠中民預測
本視頻分為四個部分
首先會為大家簡要介紹一下Secret Note
隨後會對新冠中民預測案例多詳細講解
分為案例介紹和案例演示兩部分
最後是總結
第一節Secret Note簡介
Secret Note是一個專為英語學藝者
和以此計算開發者設計的高級工具套件
其目的主要是為了幫助學習者和開發者
能夠快速地進行英語實驗
主要是以RootBoog的形式呈現
其由內閣式也是與RootBoog所相容的
這樣子可以使學習者和開發者
更快地上手這個實驗
Secret Note就有一下其功能特性
多節點代碼執行
英語的使用場景
或者說以此計算的時候
場景一般都是設計多節點
意思就是說在不同的節點上面
可需要執行相同或者不同的代碼
Secret Note能夠同意地管理這些節點
並且在同一個頁面上面
完成多方代碼的編寫
可以選擇在哪些節點上面進行執行
文件管理與交互式體驗
Secret Note提供文件管理功能
可以方便在不同節點上面上傳
或者下載文件
並且提供了與RootBoog類似的交互式體驗
可以方便開發者進行以實計算算法的研發
運行狀態跟蹤
Secret Note能夠跟蹤代碼的運行狀態
並且能夠實施監控節點的資源使用情況
比如CPU或者類似的
然後可以幫助開發者更好的監控和調適
Secret Note其實有兩種
一種是與Secret Floor一起使用
叫做Secret Floor to SF
一種是與Secco一起使用
叫做Secret Floor to SQL
Secret Floor to SF
如左側左邊所示
是在YouTube過程中編寫Password Lime
然後調用Secret Floor的庫
來實現相應的隱私計算任務
Secret Floor to SQL
如右側左邊所示
是在LootBook中編寫Late SoCal語句
進行Secco相關的實驗
需要注意的是Secret Note
不是為生產環境設計的
因此不建議在生產環境中直接使用
目前以與實訊平臺
提供了Secret Floor to SF的雲端版本
可以直接在線使用
不過目前沒有提供對Secret Floor to SQL的支持
需要自行在本地部署
具體如何部署可以查看Secret Floor的 GitHub倉庫
接下來我們基於雲端Secret Floor
來掩飾Secret Floor的基本使用
打開Secret Floor在線使用環境
在左側有兩個下辣框選項
LootBooks和文件
點擊這個上傳按鈕
可以上傳本地的LootBook文件
點擊這個加號
可以新建一個空白的LootBook文件
點擊新建會自動打開
我們將它重名為Test
同時我們可以在這裡將其導出到本地或者刪除
在介面的右上角可以顯示節點列表
點擊
添加節點
出入節點名稱Alice
或者其它名字都可以
添加過程大約需要30秒
愛情等待即可
好 節點添加成功
點擊節點我們可以查看節點的相關信息
比如名稱 狀態 IP 資源和版本等
線上環境節點的使用是會計時的
在左上角我們可以看到節點的使用時長和可用時長
所以當節點使用完之後
我們需要點擊刪除或者停止來結束計時
我們再新建一個節點Bob
兩個節點的使用時長是會累加的
所以不用使兩個節點都需要停止或者刪除
在線環境中最多只能添加兩個節點
節點添加成功之後
我們可以發現在左側的文件下多了兩個節點的名字
我們可以點擊上傳本地的文件到相應的節點中
需要注意的是上傳的文件
只至是以CSV或者TXT為後追名的文件
並且上傳文件的大小最大為32兆
在左下角節點監控
我們可以實時的查看各個節點的資源使用情況
主體部分和 Jupyter LootBook是一樣的
也有Markdown, Heisen 的單元格
然後點擊右上角
我們可以看到這裡有快捷鍵
Match Mini
然後點擊這個我們可以查看常用代碼段
比如獲取本方節點
單級訪真、多級訪真等
我們將獲取本方節點名的代碼添加到 LootBook 中
先將空白的單元格刪除
添加輸出
可以發現與 Jupyter LootBook所不同的是
在單元格的右上角
我們可以選擇需要執行該代碼的節點列表
我們這裡選擇 AliceBoom
都要執行
點擊執行
然後我們就可以在下面看到
所有所選節點的輸出
使用完畢之後
我們需要將節點刪除或者停止
我們這裡後續不需要用到這個節點
所以我們將其刪除
雲端 Secret Loot 使用也是到此結束
第二節 案例介紹
本視頻要介紹的案例是新冠中壁預測
是從英語時訊平臺案例模板中選取的
是一個橫向聯盟學習的案例
案例的 LootBook 可以在這個點擊中查看
我們先來介紹一下案例的背景
2019年末 新冠肺炎疫情爆發
最後新冠全球病持續了有三年
對人類社會造成的聲音影響
相信觀看本視頻的各位都是過來人
我們也可以發現
其實大多數反染新冠病毒的人的中壤表清
無需特殊治療者的倉庫
但是老獵人以及患有心血管疾病
糖尿病
慢性呼吸道疾病和癌症等潛在疾病的人
更容易患上重病 危機生命
基於遺傷背景 醫療機構ADS
與醫療機構B BOLD
希望通過聯合數據分析建立一個醫療診斷模型
可以根據新冠患者的當前症狀狀況和病史
來提高預測患者是否處於高風險的準確性
以便於有效的分配醫療資源
來挽救更多的生命
介紹完案例的背景
我們接下來介紹案例的數據級
COVID-19的原始數據級來自於卡古網站
有100多萬條數據
數據級包含了21種特徵
有生存狀態
若死亡則住民死亡日期
否則住民999999999
還有接受治療的醫療單位級別
提供醫療服務的國家衛生體系肌肉類型
性別護理類型
COVID-19檢測結果
以及是否連接呼吸機
肺炮社發炎等其他部爾特徵
該案理採用橫向聯邦學習技術
需要在确保数据不出御的前提下进行跨机构的联合建模
提高医疗诊断的预测效果
推动医疗数据的安全利用与共享
原始数据机是一个大数据机
为了进行实验我们需要对原始数据机进行处理
从而构造适合本实验的数据机
首先我们需要明确
将生存状态作为标签特征
但是生存状态的取职范围过于庞大
考虑将其取职进行数据化
由于我们只关心病人是否存活
不可以将其二字化
将死亡日期自断用Y来表示
同时取职转化为零和一
一表示病人死亡
由于数据机过于庞大有57兆
大语文件上传到节点的上线
因此我们需要将
原始数据机中选取一小部分数据来进行实验
原始数据机中的
classification final 字段
表示
home v 19 检测结果
数值从1到3表示患者被整合出不同程度的新冠
我们利用此策则拿来抽取
数据机样的
在之后的数据中删掉的盖特征
原始数据机中有100多万条样本
我们最后只选取了其中一万多条
并水平切分成了两个参与方的
数据
水平分割一般用于构造很像联邦学习的数据
垂直分割一般用于构造更像联邦学习的数据
如该是一部所示
我们将原数据机扣毕自data.csv
水平分割成了
agency alice.csv
和agency boh.csv
用于模拟医疗机构
a alice的数据
agency boh.csv
用于模拟来自医疗机构b boh
数据
这两个机构的数据机
拥有完全相同的特征之段
在底下这个自愿表格中
我们可以看出相比原数据机的变化
原来的
data
data.x
变成了
classification.filo
自愿被删除
第三结
案例掩饰
接下来
给大家进行个
案例实验的掩饰
从实验的配置
到夹载
并化分数据机
到介义和训练水平模型
从而实现
安理斯和Bow Esp
加医疗机构
数据的联合分析
以及安全接磨
我们先打开 poverty law
我们先将不用的loadbook删除
我们从本地上从磁安尼的loadbook
我对官网提供的安尼loadbook进行了些微的修改
但是基本于官网上的一致
我们打开3D的loadbook
我们先清空所有的速出
然后我们添加节点
本安尼只要用到一个节点
我们将time will be COVID
节点添加需要一天时间
好,节点添加成功
然后接下来我们将要用到的双方的数据集
上传到节点中
agency alix
agency boat
好,节点上,数据上传成功
然后我们开始实验
然后实验简介
在前面我们已经介绍过了
就不细说了
然后在简介的最后
我们需要先查看一下
呃,当前passing版本和secret flow的版本
因为本实验所用到的某些类
在其他版本中是不一定能够支持的
好,可以看到secret flow的版本是1.1厘
这是能够支持本词,本词先了
呃,实验配置
然后因为在线环境最多只能添加两个节点
但是本实验是需要三个节点
所以我们只能在一个节点中
用访证模式来模拟三个节点
我们需要模拟一下医疗机构A alix
医疗机构B boat,还有server节点
一共三个节点
呃,server节点是用来
安全地整合医疗机构A和医疗机构B的数据
然后我们执行partys
就是呃,这三个要访证的节点的名字
然后地址就写local表示等地访证
spu配置
呃,医疗机构A,医疗机构B,还有server节点
需要重新的端口启动参与数,参与计算
需要执行下方的unused tsp port
方法来获取未使用的端口
然后需要注意的是,每次调用这个方法都会返回不同论址
然后我们调用三次
然后分别分配给Ages,bob和server
然后这里有个round time ip
表示是运行时的ip
我们查看节点的ip
复制过来
好,粘贴
然后因为呃,所有代码都是在同一个节点中运行的
所以我们将它复制为127.0.0.1也是可以的
让我们执行
然后我们输出呃,分配的这些端口
下面这两个,这两行代码的话是
可以获取当权机群的资源配置
然后我可以看到它输出中有
bob,server,还有Alice
那就表示这三个节点
它确实在当权机群中
创建并配置secret flaw的spu实地
我们要为所有节点都要配置
d127.0,a127.0,b127.0还有127.0
然后在load 下面的
每一个
字点就表示一个节点
然后字点中的party就是节点名
地址就是
节点的ip和端口
然后ip就是
round type
就是在下面配置的
然后这些端口就是
分别为三个节点
所分配的各自的端口
round tank and fig
round tank and fig是一些
相关的运行室配置参数
比如说使用的多方安全计算协议
和使用的有限预等
我们
之前之后可以得到一个spu实地
然后之前震撼大满
我们可以获得医疗机构a,医疗机构b
和server的pyu对象
然后之前之后
spobserver就分明表示
对应节点的pyu对象
加载命化分数级
加载数据级
我们需要加载的是水平数据
然后多出来的server节点
是需要作为数据的聚合节点
来保证数据的安全
我们先加载聚合器和比较器的类
然后我们再实地画一个spu的比较器对象
我们再实地画一个聚合器
然后聚合器这样出示的话
就表示server节点
来聚合Alice和Bob的数据
之后就是读取水平数据级
我们首先要配置一个
每方数据级所分组的路径
然后因为上传的文件临时在
当权录定下
所以我们可以直接将对应的数据文件名作为持
执行水平的readcsv
然后我传入文件路径
然后聚合器和比较器
我们可以得到
又得到一个水平的take-off rate hdf
我们分别运行
hdf.chip和hdf.clones
我们可以得到
得到数据的大小
大小是
然后本时间控加载
一万零四百五十二条样本
然后每个样本有二十个特征
所以数据的大小是真的大小
我们可以获得
这个数据的列名
拥有二十个列名
数据化分
模型的训练是需要
将数据化分为训练级和测试级的
我们设定的训练级和测试级的
样本比例是8比2
测试型代码就可以将计画分
水平差级固字的建模
本时间的水平建模方法选择是
差级固字的算法
而差级固字的
是一种高效的T度提升数算法
中国加反模型和正则化方式过离合
后支持变形与缺失值处理
广泛用于数结构化数据的分类回归任务
首先是设置差级固字的超参数
超参数的设置可以在
这个链接中进行详细的查感
我们设置MaxDip对三
每个数最大是三成
再大就容易过离合
一天是缺席率
也设为0.1
objective就是指定任务类
类型为二分类的逻辑回归
在注射后面也提供了很多其他的客源值
然后metric是log lose
对数损失
训练时用的评估指标
level key是y
我们在购到数据级的时候也有提到
作为样本的标签
然后实际化sf charge boost
sf charge boost是secret flow
对charge boost的封装实现
要注意到是
只有在secret flow
小于等于1.10的时候
是可以使用的
大于1.10的话
它不只是sf charge boost
我们自行一下
sf charge boost的处置化
设置server是server
client就是annis和bub
这两个数据级点
好,根据训练级
你可归在测试集中进行验证
然后我们运行正和大码
就可以训练这个
charge boost的模型
好,我们设置的
boost的伦出式试论
好,训练完成
我们先将
训练的模型保存下来
然后我们在
分别运行对Test级的测试
和对训练级的测试
我们可以查看它最后的评估指标
就是对数损失
它的指相应的都是比较接近的
然后而且都是比较小的
好
安妮也是实验到此结束
第四节
总结
本安妮描述了医疗机构annis
与医疗机构bub合作的实际场景
通过联合数据分析
构建一个用于浴车covid-19
患者重病风险的医疗整段模型
模型根据患者的症状
病史和健康状况
判断其是否处于高风险状态
从而优化医疗资源分配
安妮采用隐私保护技术很像联盟学习
确保数据在不出御的情况下
进行跨机构联合建模
提高浴车准结性
并促进医疗数据的安全共享
在最后提供了
本视频所涉及的
网站 仓库 文档等资源的链接
注意仓库和文档查看白本需要对应
好的 那么本视频到此结束
谢谢大家的观看